today on the matt wall show the what is
a woman movement makes it all the way to
the supreme court as judge jackson
reveals that though she wants to be on
the supreme court she cannot answer the
most basic questions about reality she
also has a tenuous grasp of justice as
her lenient approach to child porn cases
demonstrates talk about all that today
plus governor desantis declares the real
winner of the race that leah thomas won
by cheating espn is now woke on steroids
and harry's jealous of our success with
jeremy's razors accuses the daily wire
of hate speech plus kid rock explains
how to become uncancelable and president
biden declares a new world order using
those exact words all of that and more
today on the matt welsh show
[Music]
do you have an account with coinbase or
are you thinking of opening one with an
alto crypto ira you can trade crypto
like bitcoin and avoid or defer their
taxes get into investing in crypto and
do it in a tax advantage retirement
account they offer industry-leading
security and trading 24 7 through alto's
integration with coinbase there are 80
plus coins available including bitcoin
ethereum and cardano alto's crypto ira
is the easy way to get crypto into an
ira trade all you want without the tax
headache create an account with ulta
crypto ira in just a few minutes and
invest with as little as ten dollars
plus there's no setup charges multiple
ways to fund your account you make a
cash contribution transfer cash from an
existing ira or roll over an old 401k
open an alto crypto ira account with as
little as ten dollars just go to altoira
dot com slash matt that's a l t o i r a
dot com slash matt go to alto ira dot
com slash met
the confirmation hearings for contanji
brown jackson took a shocking turn
yesterday when republicans made the bold
and controversial decision
to ask the judge about her resume and
her judicial philosophy her rulings her
fundamental beliefs
breaking from recent tradition they for
whatever reason did not ask jackson how
many beers she drank in college nor did
they inspect her high school yearbook
for potential vulgarities democrats
claim that jackson has been treated
unfairly one can only assume that this
is what they mean she's been treated
like a judge seeking the highest
judicial appointment in the land and not
like an alleged criminal on trial by a
kangaroo court
that's what essentially separates the
way republicans handle these sorts of
things from the way democrats handle
them but of course it's already known
ahead of time that any line of
questioning directed at jackson will be
out of bounds and racist
at least any questioning outside of
questions like what's your favorite
flavor of ice cream and
have you always been this wonderful
the left made that explicitly clear from
the outset though they didn't need to be
explicit this is how the game is played
according to the long established rules
yet in spite of the inherent racism of
demanding that a black woman explain
herself when all she wants to do is
become a supreme court justice
there is uh based on her record and her
worldview
quite a lot to explain
many of the questions about jackson um
and and to her as well have focused
rightfully so on her lengthy history of
leniency towards child sex predators
especially people who consume child
pornography who are also child sex
predators by definition
the rnc research account lists several
cases where jackson passed down a
sentence significantly below
federal sentencing guidelines in fact
this is how she handled every child porn
case she encountered every single one
she passed down a sentence below federal
guidelines so for example in one case a
man who had images of
eight-year-old children
pornographic images was supposed to be
sentenced to 10 years according to the
guidelines she gave him three months
in another a predator with 48 files of
child porn on his computer was subject
to 97 months in prison
jackson cut that into a third giving him
28.
um in still another case a pervert who
posted a pornographic image of a
five-year-old was given by jackson the
lowest possible sentence allowed by the
law just 60 months
now one thing you might take away from
this
is that the federal guidelines are far
too lenient already
i see no reason why child porn users and
distributors
should not be given mandatory life
sentences this should be like a one
strike in your out kind of situation
these are not people we need in society
you do something like that it should be
okay we don't need you
in society you're gone and you're never
coming back
and yet
the soft guidelines were still not soft
enough for jackson who seems to have a
soft spot in her heart for child sex
perverts
now what can she say for herself to
justify this well to explain at least
one of these cases
she said that the lenient sentence was
due in part to the child predators
diplomas and certificates listen
he presented all of his diplomas and
certificates and the things that he had
done
and argued
consistent with what i was seeing in the
record
that this particular defendant
had
gotten into this in a way that was i
thought inconsistent with some of the
other cases that i had seen part of what
a judge is doing
as
required by congress
is
thinking about
this case
thinking about unwarranted sentencing
disparities that's in the statute
other cases other determinations that a
judge may have made about this
i don't remember in detail this
particular case but i do recall it being
unusual
now at another point she argued that her
lighter touch on this issue has
sometimes been due to the disparities in
the system the fact that
the federal guidelines for child porn
sentencing were first established back
when child porn users had to obtain
images through the mail and this for
some reason is significant in a means
that sometimes the sentence should be
lighter than the guidelines allow let's
listen to that
as you said the guideline was based
originally on
a statutory scheme and on directives
specific directives by congress at a
time
in which
more serious child pornography
offenders were identified based on
the volume
based on the number of photographs that
they received in the mail and that made
totally total sense
before
when we didn't have the internet when we
didn't have distribution but the way
that the guideline is now structured
based on that set of circumstances
is leading to extreme disparities in the
system
because
it's so easy for people to get
volumes of this kind of material now by
computers
so it's not doing the work
of differentiating who is a more serious
offender in the way that it used to
so the commission has taken that into
account and and perhaps even more
importantly courts
are adjusting their sentences
in order to account for the change
circumstances but it says nothing about
the court's view of the seriousness of
this offense
so the argument is that punishing
someone for each image they obtain was
fair back when they had to have the
images mailed to them but now that it's
so easy to get hundreds of images at
once it's not fair that's the argument
and it's a very very bad argument
and you know it's a bad argument because
over on cnn infamous public masturbator
jeffrey toobin was agreeing with it it
seems that tuban having already
displayed his tube on a zoom call is now
incapable of experiencing any further
shame or embarrassment either that or he
enjoys it the freak whatever his reasons
tuban with his hands suspiciously out of
view said this
can i just had one point about these
these kitty porn cases and and this this
came up i remember when i was an
assistant us attorney back in the 90s is
that when those uh
when those uh sentencing guidelines were
written for those cases
that this was a time when
uh the people who committed these crimes
would order individual photos and and
and get and then get them usually
through email
and then uh they would be sentenced
based on the number of photos they
possessed
this was all pre-internet so
once the internet came in and and people
got
access to hundreds and then thousands of
photos they would the the sentencing
guidelines would reflect hundreds and
then thousands of photos federal judges
have been struggling with the issue of
how do you create a fair system that was
designed pre-internet that was
yet you have to sentence people post
internet and what i thought chairman
durbin pointed out is that judges across
the country
including republican appointed judges
have been saying look we can't apply the
rules um
pre that were designed pre-internet for
an internet society and many judges have
been giving somewhat less sentences as a
result
now far be it for me to get into an
argument with the sort of man who
doesn't wear
pants to a work meeting
especially when the argument is about
pornography but you know i'm not
convinced by this reasoning if anything
it seems clear to me the sentences
should be harsher now
because of the ease of access
it's exactly the reason that they're
calling for lighter sentences that's why
there should be harsher sentences
because it necessitates a greater level
of deterrence it means that we we must
make an even more drastic example out of
each offender
because of how easy this stuff is to
obtain
the message from society should be
we find a file of child porn on your
computer and you're done forever your
life is over
yet both jackson and tuban believe that
the more
crime the more that this crime
proliferates the more common it becomes
the less we should penalize it
now one might wish that this is about as
weird as things would get but judge
jackson is at bottom a leftist and that
means that the moral bewilderments and
intellectual incoherence goes much
deeper i mean this is a woman who is
tragically confused not just about the
concept of justice already a troubling
source of confusion for a judge but also
about the basic realities of life
including what what life even is and
when life begins and asks that question
here was her answer listen
when does life begin
in your opinion
senator um
i don't
no
now there's of course no excuse for not
being able to answer that question the
only sensible starting point for life is
the moment when you come into existence
as a distinct human entity otherwise
known as conception
any other starting point that you might
choose will be necessarily arbitrary
there's only one solid firm
sensible starting point which is
conception but here's the thing
if she really doesn't know
when life begins
then that's all the more reason to be
stridently pro-life
and anti-abortion
because by jackson's own words as far as
she knows
abortion might well be the murder of
human life i mean if she doesn't know
when life begins then she cannot say
that abortion does not murder
destroy human life
according to her the abortion industry
may well have murdered 60 million human
lives since roe v wade
now i know for a fact not that it may
well have murdered 60 million human
lives but that it did
but you don't even need in order to get
to the pro-life anti-abortion conclusion
you don't even need to go that far
the the the maybe the might that i don't
know
if you're a rational and moral person
that should be enough to get you to the
anti-abortion
conclusion
because if it's possible
even if it's even possible
that this mass genocide is happening if
it's a 50-50 toss-up as she seems to
think then the only moral and defensible
position to take is one of treating the
unborn child as human life
to return to an analogy that i've made
before supporting abortion when you
don't know when life begins it's like
tossing a live grenade into a room
when you don't know if there's anybody
in there or not you know it is at best
morally incoherent to say i don't know
when life begins but i support abortion
anyway
speaking of incoherent nothing of course
can top this
do you agree with justice ginsburg that
there are physical differences between
men and women that are enduring
senator
respectfully i
am not familiar with that particular
quote or case okay so it's hard for me
to
okay comment as to whether all right i'd
love to get your
your opinion on on that and you can
submit that do you interpret justice
ginsburg's
meaning of men and women as male and
female
again because i don't know the case i
don't know how i interpret it i need to
read the whole okay
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me a
definition
senator in my work as a judge what i do
is i
address disputes if there's a dispute
about a definition people make arguments
and i look at the law and i
decide
yeah i think we can officially now say
that the what is a woman movement has
begun when i started asking this
question years ago i dreamed i honestly
dreamed of a
moment just like this
where someone like this is asked a
question like that very simple
in this sort of context
because as we witness there the whole
house of cards comes tumbling down under
the very meager weight of one extremely
simple question
and the irony here is so rich so grand
that it's almost impossible to fully
appreciate and wrap your arms around
we've been breathlessly told that we
should celebrate jackson jackson's
nomination precisely because she's a
black woman
but jackson herself can't even tell us
what a woman is how can we celebrate the
nomination of a woman if the people
telling us to celebrate it can't define
the word
so they say celebrate her well why
because she's a woman damn it
what's that uh i don't know
well okay then let me go get the
champagne
of course jackson's dodge is that she's
not a biologist
but saying you can't define woman
without a biology degree it's like
saying that you can't solve for five
plus five without a degree in
mathematics
it's like saying you can't define the
word car if you're not a mechanic or
fish if you're not a marine biologist
it's like saying you have to be a
world-class artist to explain what a
crayon is
this is all a bunch of unintelligible
irrational rambling nonsense
now is the fact that jackson doesn't
know what a woman is
relevant to her job
well yes i would think it's quite
relevant to a supreme court justice and
their job to know whether they have a
basic grasp on reality
and it's relevant for another reason
because we all know
that obviously she knows what a woman is
she knows the answer to the question
she's not that stupid
i mean if she doesn't know
then she is without a doubt the dumbest
supreme court nominee in the history of
the united states she is the dumbest
person to ever even be considered for
the job
and should be disqualified on those
grounds alone
but i'm going to give her more credit
than that
i don't think she's nearly that stupid
there's no way that she could make it as
far as she has
being that stupid
so no she knows what a woman is
she knows today
she's always known she'll know tomorrow
but she's so beholden to left-wing
orthodoxy so firmly embedded in that
world so committed to it that she will
pretend she doesn't know
humiliating herself on the national
stage in the process
that's what makes her dangerous on the
supreme court
and yet this question as i've been
insisting for years is the question
that single-handedly destroys gender
ideology and reveals leftism for what it
is
and what is it it's a movement of moral
and intellectual chaos
it rejects truth categorically
it's a form of madness ideological
madness madness that you choose to buy
into and adopt as your world view
lunacy
it turned into a world view is what
leftism is
but most of all it's flimsy it's hollow
at its core
defeated by the most basic line of
inquiry
destroyed by questions
questions that we just have to have
the guts to ask finally
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know when you look around at the
world today and at our country which is
collapsing into a heap before our very
eyes it can be
difficult
to sleep you know you could toss and
turn at night thinking about uh the
collapse of human civilization but it's
a little bit easier when you have helix
sleep helix sleep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you why would
you buy a mattress made for somebody
else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep everybody's unique
and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains helix
is uh just awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq and wired magazine so
just go to helixsleep.com walsh take
their two minute sleeve quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life they have a 10-year warranty and
you can get it
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix has enough financing
options and flexible payment plans so
that a great night's sleep is never far
away you can wake up in the morning and
think again about how
uh civilization is ruined but at least
you can sleep well at night helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep dot com wall
street's helix sleep dot com slash walls
for up to 200 off and two free pillows
alright we'll start with this from
governor ron desantis he tweeted by
allowing men to compete in women's
sports the ncaa is destroying
opportunities for women making a mockery
of its championships and perpetuating a
fraud in florida we reject these lies
and recognize sarasota's emma wyant
as the best women's swimmer in the 500
yard freestyle and
then he has his official declaration
from the governor with the seal there
just reiterating reiterating again that
emma wyant who came in quote unquote
second behind the mail
leah thomas it is in fact the winner
of the uh
of the race this is
i don't know if i've mentioned this
before but i'll
maybe i have a time or two
that governor ron desantis needs to be
our guy in 2024.
um he he just
we're
we we want to lose
you know as conservatives if we
[Music]
decide to throw him to the side and pick
somebody else he's by by far the most
effective republican governor in the
country and
the other thing from a political
perspective
you know he under he has he understands
that something like this is a winning
issue
he knows what the winning issues are for
republicans
i think more and more republicans are
awakening to this it took them long
enough
but governor desantis has his finger on
the pulse as it were and really
understands it
this is
by far and away a winning move
to say
this um and he also says it's very
important the language is important he
didn't say because i think you know if
if another republican had done a similar
thing and now that he's done this i'm
sure other republicans will start doing
it as well
but
most republicans if they were to do
something like this they would probably
say if they would even go as far as this
they would say by allowing trans women
to compete in women's sports
but he uses the word man and that's very
important
taking a stand saying no this is a man
and that's it
you know as i've been saying for so long
this is a winning issue for republicans
it's an important issue
and it's an issue that the democrats
they they don't want to have a
conversation about it now
they want to talk about it they want to
talk at you about
gender and about trans rights and about
all these things
so it's not to say they don't want to
talk about i mean they obviously want to
talk about it they talk about it all the
time
they're screaming in our faces about it
all the time they want to march through
the street screaming about it into a
bullhorn they love talking about it but
they don't want to have a conversation
about it
now you could point out that the
democrats don't really want to have a
conversation about anything and that's
true but especially with this
it can't be a back and forth it's just
here's what we're saying about quote
unquote trans rights and that's it
they don't want any kind of back and
forth at all
they don't want to be asked questions
about it
any questions
i mean we we're going to get to a point
where it's it's going to be almost
inevitable
as much as the media doesn't want to
have to do it you keep this issue at the
forefront
what is a woman
you keep that
at the forefront as well we're going to
get to the debate season in midterms and
presidential election where this that
question what is a woman is going to
come up in the debates
um
again it's not it's not something that
any moderator would want to ask because
they're all on the sides of the
democrats and they know how embarrassing
the question is
but it's gonna it's gonna be so much to
the forefront if we keep pushing it
there you you have to ask it
and if the moderator doesn't ask it then
republican you ask it
um this is something that ron desantis
if he was in a presidential debate he
would certainly do
and they can't they that's a question
they can't answer they don't want to
answer any question about this and
listen to me when i say this i mean any
question
when it comes to gender ideology
they don't want to and cannot answer
literally any question on the subject
and that's why our job is to ask those
questions
meanwhile elsewhere in florida um
actually no this was in california i
guess disney employees had a walkout
over the uh the bill in florida the
don't say gay bill which they invented
in their heads the bill that doesn't
exist actually doesn't exist in florida
it doesn't exist anywhere it exists in
their fevered imaginations
um
and uh here's that walkout let's let's
take a listen
i mean this is this is just heroism
they're marching down
in california shouting the word gay say
gay say gay
haven't read the bill haven't read the
bill that's really what the what the
march the chant should be
um
also disney related more people who
haven't read the bill espn yesterday now
i know i talk about we talk about espn
going woke it's like that's
happened a long time ago but they are
they are not relenting i mean they have
espn has chosen its path
and will not waver from it and is just
going deeper and deeper into this
madness so here is a long twitter thread
they posted yesterday
um because you know
if you if you like sports then you
follow espn on twitter right
supposedly
well you're not gonna get sports
coverage instead you get this espn
believes in inclusivity and denounces
legislation and actions across the
united states that infringe on any human
rights we stand with our
lgbtqia plus colleagues friends families
and fans
though you just love sports they
continue we'll continue to partner with
organizations that support the
lgbtqia plus community be accountable
where we fall short of expectations and
never stop telling stories about
lgbtqia plus athletes like the ones
we'll be sharing in this thread
and then uh they go into a long
list of examples transgender kids in the
u.s are stuck in the middle of the
ongoing debate over science and
assumption sex and gender identity
politics and policy
uh this is the story of becky stephanie
and chris three athletes who say they
just want to play and then there's an
article that's titled
why some states are sending transgender
athletes to the sidelines that of course
is not true
for the umpteenth time
there are no states that are doing that
there are no states that are sending
transgender athletes to the sideline uh
there's no state that has passed any law
saying that if you identify as quote
unquote transgender you cannot compete
in sports that doesn't exist nowhere in
america at any point has any quote
unquote trans person been told you're
not allowed to compete in sports what
has happened and what is happening in
certain states is that they're saying to
the trans people you in fact are not
special
so you're going to be subject to the
same rules as everybody else and
everybody else
they they
they're going to be divided up based on
biological sex determining which which
uh
you know which league they compete in
um and so you're just you are going to
be subject to the same rules as
everybody this is equality
which is what they say they want
well i i guess i'll correct myself um
it's not what they say they want anymore
they've abandoned that now they talk
about equity
and as we talked about equity and
equality are actually two entirely
separate things
all right here's uh let's move to this
joe biden with
an accidental you get these every once
in a while and maybe increasingly so
with joe biden because he doesn't
partially do the dimension everything he
doesn't have the filter like a lot of
politicians do so here's a moment of
accidental honesty from joe biden listen
you know we are at an inflection point i
believe in the world economy not just
the world economy in the world it occurs
every three or four generations
as one of them as the one of the top
military people said to me in a secure
meeting the other day
60 60 million people died between 1900
and 1946
and
since then we established a liberal
world order and that hadn't happened in
a long while a lot of people dying but
nowhere near the chaos
and now is the time when things are
shifting we're gonna they're gonna be a
new world order out there and we've
gotta lead it we've gotta unite the rest
of the free world and doing it
doesn't just say it once he says it he
repeats it
this is a liberal world order a new
world order
uh that's his own words
you know anybody else were to say that
and accuse
the left of wanting to establish a new
world order then it's a great conspiracy
theory and you probably get banned from
twitter and youtube or whatever for
saying it but uh here he is saying it
himself of course the new world order is
was
was never
even a theory
there might be a conspiracy there's
certainly an element of conspiracy to it
um i think a lot of it is an unspoken
conspiracy that's the thing about the
so-called conspiracies on the left they
are engaged in lots of conspiracies and
all of the most powerful institutions in
the country are in a way conspiring
amongst themselves but they don't need
to
most of the time they don't need to meet
in smoky rooms and uh and hatch their
evil plans they're just all sort of on
the same page automatically
their their ideology puts them on the
same page
and uh they want the same things
but
the idea that they want to reshuffle the
world order
of course they do
that's incredibly obvious
um
it's
in fact that a new world order if
anything it understates what they're
trying to do they're not just trying to
reorder things within the world they're
trying to change
reality itself they're they want a new
reality order or something like that
they want they want to
fundamentally change
the realities of the universe which
cannot be changed but that's what they
want to
and if they cannot change the basic
realities of life
then it's then the next option
is to um indoctrinate
you know a country full of people and
especially generations younger
generations of people who don't
recognize basic realities
so it's pretty clear that that's what
they want to do
all right um
moving along pretty fast there's a lot
to cover i want to i want to get to as
much of this as i can and i also have to
mention this yesterday we taught we
announced the unveiling of jeremy's
razors
uh which is our
response to
harry's razors which we used to
advertise on all the shows and then um
they they got wind of the fact that
michael knowles stated
that men are men and women are women
because one
twitter account with two followers said
hey did you know they believe this
meanwhile it's like all of our shows
talk about that all the time and harry's
pretended that they had no idea and then
one twitter file twitter account with
two followers says it brings it up to
them and then they denounce us and
uh say they want nothing to do with us
we launched jeremy's razors um and hear
from the daily wire now says in a
statement given to spy.com jeff raider
co-founder and co-ceo of harry's
maintained that they believed in free
speech but were drawing the line at hate
they said in a statement we created
harry's to offer better shaving and
grooming products for everyone we
believe deeply in free speech but draw
the line at hate
we'll continue to support our customers
and community with kindness and
compassion
uh spy.com added a spokesperson from the
brand continued by saying that harry's
does advertise across various media
including the conservative fox news
however the brand does not associate
with entities that engage in or endorse
hate speech
the hate speech here again is just that
men are men and women are women
in fact what it was specifically i think
was uh michael knowles talking to i
believe he's on candace owens show he's
talking with candace
and was discussing the fact that gender
dysphoria is a mental illness i think
that was the specific thing
which is all related to the fact that
men are men and women are women
um
and
the idea that that people who are
deluded about this who are confused
about what sex they are the idea that
that's a mental illness
that was the psychiatric community's
consensus if you care a lot we always
hear about the consensus of the
scientific community
well that was the consensus
view of psychiatrists and psychiatric
community up until very recently
when all of a sudden they changed it
and they said oh it's not a mental
illness
um
you know what they the way that they
flipped around is that they said okay
uh if somebody
thinks that they're born in the wrong
body
the problem it's not their the problem
is not their mental perception it's not
that they're mentally deluded because
that's what they were saying before
that's a mental illness if you think
that you're born in the wrong body or
you're a man but you think you're a
woman
for decades it was okay that's a mental
illness
um
now they say well the problem is just
the feelings the dis the dysphoric
feelings that you get from this mismatch
between your quote gender identity and
your sex
and so we have to treat the feelings
and so often the way that you treat the
feelings it turns out is through
hormones and through surgery and
everything else so that's the switch
that they made a very significant switch
really
reversing course entirely
but the interesting thing is that when
they made this switch they
there was never any scientific
explanation given for it this was a
political change
and we've seen this from the psychiatric
industry many times
where they make changes in the way that
they approach
certain proclivities
and certain delusions and so forth
and and they don't explain it on
scientific grounds it's only on
political grounds so they make the
change
but all this is hate speech now it's all
hate speech and he has no interest and
harry's has no interest in anyone who
believes anything that i'm saying right
now which is why you can get jeremy's
razors instead right i also want to play
this for you kid rock was interviewed by
tucker carlson a few days ago and he
said something about cancel culture that
i actually thought was pretty important
so i want to play that for you listen
why haven't you been canceled like
people aren't allowed to say what they
think you are i am uncancelable why is
that
because i don't give up
and i'm not in bed with any big
corporate things at the end of the day
there's nobody i'm beholden to no record
companies no corporate interests no
nothing and
you can't cancel me
i love it when they try i'm like yeah
why aren't there more artists like that
because they're in bed with record
companies and you know corporate deals
and instructors at every level and
you know it's um and if someone finds a
way to get me a little bit here and
there i'll find another way around it
you never see artists talk like that
they seem very easy to intimidate
at what point did you realize like
you're just not gonna be intimidated
day one really i think i crawled out of
the womb with both middle fingers in the
air
so
he's he's right that there are
it's an important point
that there are two ways
to get canceled
and it's really there's really only two
there are only two ways for it to happen
um two kind of categories it's just
unfortunately a great many people fall
into one of these categories or both
so either
in order to be canceled you have to be
beholden to corporate interests
um as a great many people are i mean if
you if you work for a big giant
corporation then in that way you're
beholden to them because you work for
them um
through no fault of your own i mean you
have to have a job but so that that's
one way if you're kind of at the mercy
of
giant corporations then that's one way
to get canceled
the other way is if you if you care what
the mob thinks about you
and that's why we see people who
wouldn't seem to really be beholden to
anyone there's no reason why they need
to be beholden
rich and famous people got all the money
in the world and
even if they get canceled by
corporations they're not really canceled
they're still going to be rich they're
still gonna be famous they could go out
on their own and do their own thing but
they still apologize and crumble and
everything because
although they're not really beholden to
corporate interests or maybe they are a
little bit the bigger issue is that they
care what the mob thinks
so either you care what the mob thinks
or you're holding the corporate interest
um or or both you know and for a lot of
people it's both especially a lot of
celebrities and so on the answer is both
there
so if you want to be uncancelable that's
that's the way to do it now you know
unfortunately
lots of people are not in the spot that
kid rock is in
where you can be
wealthy and all of that and you know you
don't really you're not you don't need
to go to any corporation or anyone
looking for a job you can kind of do
your own thing so not everyone's in that
spot but at least one thing that
everybody can adopt
um
is the second part
which gives you a
some cover anyway in cancel culture
which is to stop caring what the mob
thinks to begin with
a lot of the cancellations that happen
it's really a it's a it's a
self-cancellation the mob
gives the gun to the canceled person
and just convinces them to pull the
trigger against themselves
metaphorically
and you know eventually we get the point
where can't with canceled culture where
it's not so metaphorical
um and that that happens quite often
so you get you got to get to a point
where it just doesn't mean anything to
you and you realize
that first of all all these labels that
are thrown at you anytime you cancel
it's always going to be under the guise
of
racism sexism transphobia whatever
and you get to the point where you
realize that these labels don't mean
anything at all
i mean after all they're being thrown at
you by people who as we saw even on the
supreme court
or who want to be the supreme court
can't can't define a word like woman so
they certainly
it an abstract kind of concept like
transphobia that doesn't mean anything
now that really doesn't mean anything
so who cares if you're called that
and most of the people in the mob who
are coming after you and attacking you
and insulting you
they don't actually care that much
you don't mean anything to them this is
all a game to them
this is a power game power struggle
they want to impose their will on you
um
not much different from the bully in the
playground you know it's a playground
bully mentality
but
nationwide formed into a mob
ideologically driven
all right one other thing before we get
to the comment section
uh maybe you've seen this clip already
but we've we've got to play it on this
show somehow i've skipped over over the
last two days i've skipped over it but
um
you know camila harris
she has these these moments of uh real
insight
and um that i find personally inspiring
and here was another one of those
moments she's getting made fun of for
this but uh i i think she she really
makes a good point listen
the governor and i and we were all
doing a tour of the library here
and um talking about the significance of
the passage of time
right the significance of the passage of
time
so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time in terms of what we need to do to
lay these wires what we need to do to
create these jobs and there is such
great significance to the passage of
time when we think about a day
in the life of our children
the thing about the
passage of time
is that when time passes
it tends to pass and there is an effect
a passage
which is of time
and the time what it's doing is it's
passing hence therefore
the passage
and when you think about it
when you think about it
the passage of time
is really
a passage of time in which there is
a passage of time
and the time is passing
all the time
every time
great stuff from cabela harris
i i've uh
i actually have a lot of respect maybe i
shouldn't but
um
the the one thing that i do respect
about some politicians anyway
is um if you're a really good
bs artist because that that's a talent
in its own right
to be a really good bs artist
and
the ability to stand up in front of
people and say nothing at all
but sound like you're saying something
that is actually a skill and it's a
skill that unfortunately could take you
really far in life as we said it can
take you all the way
to the to the white house but with
camila harris she doesn't
she's a she's a bs artist without the
artist part of it it's just it's just
full bs she's not she she thinks that
she's good at this
and she's not and that's what makes it
so difficult to watch and listen to but
also hilarious
have you ever wanted to send your uncle
a birthday greeting from one of his
favorite conservative celebrities or
have your favorites freedom-loving
comedian roast that one liberal cousin
nobody likes in the family there's only
one place to make that a reality and
it's a new app called shout out the most
popular personalities on the right are
ready to make somebody's day with a
personalized video download shout out
now on the app store and google play to
get 20 off your first customized shout
out video from the likes of stephen
crowder the hodge twins jp series jason
whitlock or alex jones and many of your
favorite conservatives uh you could
download the shout out app today let's
get to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
okay we'll do just one video comment
this one mercifully short let's play
clip 23.
hey matt i just saw you on candace
you're totally right
all water tastes the same i drink tap
water if i need a water bottle i drink
the walmart brand because all water
tastes the same also she said there at
the very end of her show
that
you're often wrong and that we should
think about that i know we previously
declared war on ben shapiro for not
swearing allegiance to the sweet baby
inc is this war on candace
sweet baby game for life
i mean
unfortunately it is but this is not a
war that i started i mean she declared
war and sweet baby gang
by name and i have to say look what i
did talk about the show a couple days
ago the the water taste challenge that i
it was my idea
i challenged candace this because
because she
to her credit
was able to get dasani water trending on
twitter over the weekend uh talking
about how terrible dasani is and then i
discovered
much to my bewilderment that that this
is uh this is a common sentiment among
people like all kinds of people pretend
that they feel very strongly that tasani
water tastes terrible it sparks a whole
other conversation about what's your
favorite
brand of bottled water and everyone's
pretending to have a favorite brand like
they can tell the difference and my
point all along was that actually all
water tastes the same this is all
psychosomatic it's a it's a placebo
effect you think you can tell the
difference but you can't actually and so
that's why i challenged candace owens
and said let's have taste test
blind taste test
and uh and we'll see if you can actually
tell the difference like that's the best
way to go about this
and i did say initially that i want to
meet a neutral playing field which is
the break room and we'll do this taste
test and we'll see who wins you know and
it ended up being on her show instead
okay you know it's not exactly a neutral
playing field but i'll go along with it
what i will say this is all i'm going to
say about this is all i'm going to say
um
if you watch that segment on candace's
show
which you should she'll watch the whole
show but you should watch that segment
as well at the very end um you know i
think the most important segment on on
her show on any show this week is is
what we did with the with the water
tasting test
um
but
i i did win
without any question whatsoever
it ended up being a somewhat longer
segment than you might argue it needed
to be
okay it was a it was there was quite a
dispute that that occurred
not all of that makes it into the final
product because you got to cut things
down for time a little bit
but all i'm going to say is that we we
did do at least one clean take here
where
we each try that with five uh cups of
water and we didn't know what was in it
and we just tried it of course i i
always said all along i can't tell the
difference so i can tell the difference
and then she guessed and she gets wrong
she and and she wasn't able to tell the
difference either so i did win
whatever camera tricks that come up with
i don't know but i did win and so
i'm waiting
on my one hundred dollars from candace
owens and i mean
gas is expensive like i don't know how
i'm gonna get home today
i need that hundred dollars to put gas
in my car and i'm i'm waiting on her to
come through
all right this is uh from justin graham
says total boss move by the daily wire
to pull at david hogg and try to beat
the enemy at their own game but unlike
hog jeremy's razor's company will
actually be successful given daily
wire's track record well that
understates it yeah david hogg decided
he wanted to start his own pillow
company to compete with my pillow but i
think with david hockey never actually
he just announced that he wanted to do
it and the pillow company collapsed
before it even started so it was a
failed
he might be the first person in history
to ever have a failed pillow company
that never existed to begin with um this
is no this this is all this is very real
we actually did launch it and sold a
whole bunch of razors by the way so you
can go to uh i hate harry's dot com and
get your own um
let's see
uh a miller time says matt last week my
son came home from camp and said he made
a new friend that he thought was a boy
but it was a girl
that liked to be called a boy what would
your response be to your son from
context my son is nine the girls eleven
uh well i would be telling my son in a
hurry very very without using any
clever language being very upfront and
direct and straightforward and saying um
well you said this is a girl that likes
to be called a boy you say to your son
um
that is a girl
who is confused
and we feel very sorry for her that she
is confused but she's a girl and we we
refer to her as a girl we treat her as a
girl because that's what she is no
matter what she says unfortunately she's
very confused
and then the next thing that i would be
doing unfortunately you have to do this
is um i would be
doing everything i can to strongly
discourage my child from
spending a lot of time with this girl
and
uh
and the reason for that nothing you know
it's it's not an attack on the girl
herself because i feel sorry for the
girl he's only 11. she's a victim
in in this scenario
but we know and we've heard many times
and there's so many examples of this
this social contagion aspect of uh with
with gender ideology and gender
confusion
that it spreads like like a physical
virus
and so you have to do everything you can
as as a parent to shield your kids from
that
especially at this age especially at the
age of nine
you know um
very prone at that age to confusion of
all sorts and so i think you got to do
everything you can
to shield your kid but also be very very
direct with them
about about the truth
and i certainly wouldn't get in i
wouldn't bother getting into anything
about oh we got to be be respectful and
that you know it's the most important
thing here
it's of dire importance to your child
and
to the rest of his life
that you make 100 clear what the truth
is and that that truth is not going to
change no matter what anyone says
um
let's see
jennifer says thank you matt for
articulating the fundamental issue with
the so-called mental disease diagnoses
many people think they're clinically
depressed due to a chemical imbalance
when in reality they're clinically
imbalanced due to embracing
their depressive modes get off the couch
get some sunshine life is full of ups
and downs
uh to get over it yeah i mean look
i mean the get over it part it is true
you know you say it
you phrase it like that and you're gonna
feed into this thing that you're being
dismissive or whatever and um
uh and and and people aren't gonna
appreciate that and it is true that
someone who's in the grip of
despair which is what depression is it's
despair
um it's never quite as simple as just
get over it however
the rest of what you said before that
that's why i just i keep the get over it
phrase out because you don't need that
get off the couch get some ups get some
sunshine you know get some exercise that
part is also going to be seen as
dismissive but it is not because that is
actually true this is this is just a
fact
that things like sunshine things like
exercise movement you know doing things
just getting out like trying not to
think about it as much
getting actively involved in life that
does make a huge difference
even to someone who's in the grip of of
unthinkable despair
i'm not saying it's going to
automatically let's say you walk outside
it's a sunny day and it immediately goes
away but it will make a big difference
this is a psychological fact it's a
scientific fact as well
um and the fact that we're not allowed
to talk about this or acknowledge it
acknowledge that things like exercise um
help to cure depression like we're not
it's just a fact but we're not allowed
to acknowledge it because it's seen
somehow as
uh well dismissive which it isn't
um
max winter says when i was a kid even my
parents noticed that i had a lot of
symptoms of adhd i was easily distracted
i had trouble completing things on my
own
i was i was always very active and had a
very active imagination to the point
where my parents thought i was on some
part of the autism spectrum yet they
never chose to take me to a doctor and
have me diagnosed with any of this since
they knew this was just normal behavior
for a child especially a boy
and they knew that whatever kind of help
i would be given was just a medication
that's it well i think your parents made
the right
decision and you know the thing is you
hear from parents
talking about their own kids and with
adhd in kids
the vast majority of cases it is going
to be boys
and that's something that maybe we
should stop and think about right there
if this is a mental illness that's
entirely in the brain and it's about
chemical imbalances or whatever then why
it seems really odd that it happens to
afflict boys most of the time
it just so happens to afflict
the kinds of people who are naturally
energetic naturally have more trouble
focusing especially in a public school
environment where they're being told to
sit at a at a desk for seven hours a day
and do busy work
that's just not that's actually not it's
not a natural environment
that is conducive
to children thriving especially boys
but what you hear from parents is uh you
know when you say this kind of thing
they'll say oh well you don't understand
because um you know my son yeah he's
energetic and he has trouble focusing
but it's way worse than
what you're talking about it's it's it's
like to another level and that's why his
adhd first of all how do you know
i mean
you're just assuming this is this is
your one experience you know you have
maybe one son maybe two or whatever but
but um
and you know with your child that he has
a lot of trouble focusing you're just
you're just kind of assuming that it's
so much worse than what anybody else
deals with
um i don't i don't think that that i
don't think there's any
basis for that
assumption and that's that's one of the
fundamental problems with the adhd thing
is you break it down you're talking
about attention deficit there's a
someone has a deficit of attention
has a deficient ability to pay attention
well in order to make that
determination about someone
you first have to know how much
attention they're supposed to have
what's the baseline
in order to know that they are deficient
of it
how in the world do you measure that
and then it complicates matters when you
realize that especially with kids and
especially with boys and especially in
the public school environment the
baseline for their attentional abilities
is extremely low already
so that's the issue five excellent news
for you in a world of woke razors sold
by men who cave to the demands of social
justice warriors you can now use a razor
that pivots but does not cave to anyone
and yes i'm talking about the daily wire
and our new razor company jeremy's
razors we launched a razor company
yesterday and already the response has
been enormous with razors jeremy's
razors even trending on twitter we're
taking the power out of the hands of
what corporations like harry's instead
of capitulating to corporations that
hate us we're building our own world
we're already doing
all of that with our new our news uh you
know articles our books our movies and
shows and so much more
but this is your chance to join us go to
i hate harry's dot com and place your
first order for jeremy's razors today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
the comedian jeff foxworthy was trending
on social media last night after the
release of his netflix special called
good old days from what i understand
though i haven't watched the set the
humor is very safe staying away from
anything that might be considered
political or topical
apparently he doesn't even joke about
rednecks anymore according to reports
anyway which which i hope are mistaken
reports but
for whatever reason one brief and rather
routine bit from the special was being
discussed last night and i you know i i
made it onto my radar because i saw it
on social media
and um anyway take a listen
but i had a great childhood you know i
got i played every sport
for the recreation center my parents
didn't make me pick one sport because
they thought i was going to play
professional whatever i played every
sport and it was weird back then because
if you wanted a trophy you had to finish
in first place
it was nuts
now it's pretty standard fare
complaining about participation trophies
it's uh it's cliche but we've all done
it and for good reason you know i can
still remember the first participation
trophy that i ever received at the age
of like seven six or seven
after a little league season in which we
didn't win a single game and i'm not
sure that we even had one base hit
between us on the whole team
and um i was brought to the trophy
ceremony and i assumed that my team
would be sitting there in shame watching
as the better teams are awarded for
their achievements the best team in the
league was was very impressive they
actually had four base hits that season
so those mlb caliber teams
did all receive their trophies but then
confusingly we were called to the stage
also and not to be locked in stockade so
the better teams could throw tomatoes at
us and mock us for our failures as i
first thought might happen
but to give us our own trophies the
dreaded participation trophies
we were awarded just for showing up even
though we barely did that i mean the
thing about baseball is that there's
there's nothing about it which requires
you to work hard
it's not like completing a marathon you
know i could almost agree with some form
of participation trophy for completing a
marathon just because the mere act of
doing it and finishing it
is an achievement in its own right
but in baseball
if you want you can sit out in the
outfield in a lawn chair and just watch
the clouds go by which is basically how
i spent nine years of little league
minus the lawn chair
it's absurd to award us for
participating in something so leisurely
as that
and i saw that even then at the age of
six or seven
so i therefore understand why so many
people for so many years have complained
about participation trophies
i also see how these trophies are
symbolic in a bigger sort of way
representing
the coddled self-congratulatory entitled
lazy self-esteem focused attitude that
affects modern society
and yet there's a point about all of
this and participation trophies
specifically
which has always bothered me so now i'm
using this one little jeff foxworthy
joke as an excuse to make it here's the
point and it's very simple
so often boomers
like foxworthy are the ones complaining
about participation trophies and
labeling my generation the millennials
the participation trophy generation
and yet not to split hairs here boomers
but well
you're the ones who gave us the trophies
you invented the concept or at least
popularized it
it's not like we at the age of seven
staged some sort of mutiny at the trophy
ceremony and forced you to give us
trophies at gunpoint no you came up with
the concept of participation trophies
and gave them to us and then 20 years
later you look around and say these
damned kids and their participation
trophies do you see the problem here
why did the boomers
give out participation drugs well i mean
why did they cuddle their children in so
many ways why did they raise their kids
to cherish self-regard and self-esteem
above everything else
why did they tell us that we're all
precious little diamonds who are perfect
and above reproach in every way
well before we talk about why
we just need to reiterate that
this is what they did
we didn't come up with any of this stuff
ourselves
as for why
part of it is the collapse of meaning
tied to the collapse of faith which left
a hole in the heart of our culture and
in each individual which for decades now
we've been trying to fill with self-love
self-affirmation
our own quote unquote truth
but on a more psychological level
the boomers were also prolific divorcers
um they sparked an epidemic of divorce i
mean boomers are getting divorced you
think it's bad now
um talk about the height of the boomer
divorce epidemic
tearing families apart turning their
children into latchkey kids who spent
all day in government school came home
to empty houses while both parents
worked and were raised by the tv
much of the coddling and spoiling was
out of guilt it was a form of
overcompensation
i went to school with a whole lot of
kids from broken families and almost all
of them
had nicer toys than than i did
part of that is because their parents
valued material wealth above everything
else in life and part of that is because
their parents were constantly trying to
buy their affection
the point here is that whether you're
talking about participation trophies or
anything else
when you complain about your children's
generation
you're complaining about yourself
because a new generation does not fall
out of the sky
they aren't they aren't actually
delivered by storks they don't they
don't climb out of tombs like zombies or
mummies they don't materialize out of
thin air
despite how some people in my generation
might physically appear we're also not
orcs dug out of the ground like in lord
of the rings
generations are raised by the generation
before them
they're conditioned for better or worse
they enter into a world that they didn't
create
so much about them is ultimately decided
by the people who came before them
that's not an excuse it's just a simple
basic fact of human life
and it's a fact that boomers as a group
have never been willing to accept
you rarely see boomers look around at
their children and grandchildren and say
my god
where did we go wrong
you rarely hear see that instead they
talk about this like they had nothing to
do with it
like they in fact are guilty they in
fact are victims
of the culture that they created
that level of introspection saying where
do we go wrong seems to exceed their
grasp in many cases it also exceeds the
grasp of my generation just as it will
for the generation
after us generation z and the ones after
them
self you know self introspection
um
see is a lost art self-obsession
obsession we have we're obsessed with
ourselves
but actually
you know thinking critically about
ourselves and our own choices and our
own lives that's something that almost
nobody in this country seems able to do
and this is why we have to face these
hard truths
there is a generation of children right
now
who collectively at the current rate are
doomed to become something really quite
monstrous as they grow older there will
be exceptions i'm determined that my own
kids will be among the exceptions but as
a group the results are not going to be
pretty unless there's a drastic cultural
sea change right now
something i'm not holding my breath for
and then when our kids generation the
the generation of kids right now
when they come of age
you know those of us who are older we're
going to survey the damage and scratch
our heads and say how could this have
happened
well it happened because we happened
that's how it happened
time to take ownership
and for this reason
jeff foxworthy is cancelled
how to cancel someone so it comes back
down around to a jeff foxworthy
kind of collateral damage in all of this
but what can i do
uh we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire
on today's episode the cdc reduces the
covet death count the ukraine war takes
a toll on the wheat supply and the
drought in california adds to the
growing food crisis
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire